there was a very very interesting
interview over the weekend on Fox News
Sunday which is Fox News's version of
the sort of Sunday morning political
talk show and Chris Wallace pointed out
to Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
during this interview that the world
community sort of at large is
increasingly concerned with Donald
Trump's seemingly casual or even
accepting attitude towards really
horrific and vile racism and xenophobic
groups and people for example the United
Nations recently condemned Trump for not
condemning racism in the wake of the
charlottesville debacle that took place
during our vacation and Chris Wallace
asked Rex Tillerson does do the values
of President Trump align with what we
consider to be American values and Rex
Tillerson the top diplomat of the United
States said hey Donald Trump speaks only
for himself purely finally and I've got
a little over a minute left the
controversy over the racial protests in
Charlottesville and the president's
response to it has become an
international issue a UN committee this
week criticized the Trump administration
for quote its failure at the highest
political level to unequivocally reject
and condemn the racist violent events
and demonstrations and here was the
president in Phoenix this week talking
more about the media than he was about
the neo-nazis in the Klan here he is the
only people giving a platform to these
hate groups is the media itself in the
fake good does that make it harder for
you to push American values around the
world when some foreign leaders question
the president's values Chris we express
America's values from the State
Department we represent the American
people we represent America's values our
commitment to freedom our commitment to
equal treatment of people the world over
and that message has never changed and
when the president gets into the kind of
controversy he does in the UN Committee
responds the way as it seems to say they
begin to doubt our whether we're living
those values
I don't believe anyone doubts the
American people's values or the
commitment of the American government or
the government's agencies to advancing
those values and defending those values
and the president's values the president
speaks for himself Chris are you
separating yourself from that sir
I've spoken I've made my own comments as
to our values as well in a speech I gave
to the State Department this past week
Wow I just realized by the way that Rex
Tillerson is like a Texas version of
Sean Connery talking about expressing
his values I know this kind of seems
like okay no big deal there's way
crazier stuff going on and that's true
but this is the Secretary of State
saying listen Trump says what he says
I've spoken about my values and he is
clearly distancing himself in the
American people at large from the values
that Trump seems to portray and rightly
so I mean Trump seems to have no real
values to speak of other than cronyism
deranged grandiosity and greed and so
much nonsense has been normalized by
sort of the sheer idiocy of the Trump
administration this could easily get
lost in the mix the Secretary of State
is on national media not acknowledging
that his values are in line with those
of the President of the United States
for whom he works this is a big deal and
I really think that tiller since
comments here were planned out it wasn't
like it was a gaffe or anything that he
accidentally said yeah normally this
would be you know the response would be
some sort of firing or his forced
resignation but I just think that Rex
Tillerson understands that Donald Trump
doesn't really have the political
capital at this point to do that yeah
because he's been firing way too many
people it's like The Apprentice and the
Secretary of State is just such an
important role it's funny how people
that I would never normally agree with
on anything sort of come through his
voices of reason when compared to Donald
Trump like Jim mattis doesn't know
whether this total ban on the
transgender community from the military
makes total sense Wow seems
comparatively reasonable Secretary of
State Tillerson doesn't think an
escalation of megalomaniacs into World
War three v's of either North Korea
situation is a great idea seems kind of
reasonable the
of Overton Window of insanity is moving
under Trump because he's just so out
there on so many issues and it might be
because Tillerson is making his exit
strategy for leaving the White House
soon and as a guy who's been in business
his whole life and now as a diplomat
yeah I mean PR is very important to him
so he can't just tacitly agree with the
comments that Trump made on
charlottesville I don't agree with the
guy on basically any of his politics but
you can't really say Tillerson is not a
careful guy when it comes to what he
says publicly